Hamburg
die Männer die hier vor den Monitoren
sitzen sind keine Computerspezialisten
sie sind schiffskapitäne von diesem
Kontrollzentrum ausleiten sie 180
Frachtschiffe auf der ganzen Welt
ihr Ziel die Sicherheit der Flotte zu
gewährleisten ihr handwerkszeugrechner
die Wetter Gezeiten und Strömungen in
Echtzeit analysieren
heutzutage werden fast alle Ozeanriesen
auf diese Weise überwacht hätte es diese
Technologie bereits 2012 gegeben wäre es
vielleicht möglich gewesen eine der
schlimmsten schifffahrtskatastrophen der
letzten Jahre zu verhindern
Costa Concordia ein Name der traurige
Berühmtheit erlangte ein schwimmendes
Paradies das sich in einen Albtraum
verwandelte
bitte verlassen sie das Schiff verlassen
sie das Schiff begeben Sie sich zu den
rettungsboten bewahren Sie bitte Ruhe
sie hatte doppelt so viele Passagiere an
Bord für die Titanic die Bilder des
Unglücks gegen um die Welt aber was sind
die technischen Hintergründe die am 13
januar 2012 zum Desaster führten
ein paar Minuten nach der Kollision war
das Schiff komplett manövrierunfähig und
nicht mehr zu kontrollieren
auf der Suche nach Antworten sprechen
wir mit Ingenieuren Schiffsbauern
Kapitänen
und auch mit Menschen die die
Katastrophe selbst erlebt haben
ich hörte dieses Geräusch vom
Schiffsrumpf
es war so als würden wir über den
Meeresboden Schrammen
Originalaufnahmen von Bord des
Kreuzfahrtschiffs und die Aufzeichnung
des stimmenrekorders geben einen
Einblick in den Ablauf des Unglücks
alles ist überflutet das Kontrollpult
ist komplett unter Wasser bitte Kapitän
doch das Unglück führte auch zu einer
technischen Meisterleistung hunderte
Ingenieure und Schiffsbauer arbeiteten
über zwei Jahre daran die Costa
Concordia wieder aufzurichten und
schwimmfähig zu machen
viele jeden das für unmöglich
es war die größte tauchoperation der
Geschichte
das havarierte Schiffswrack zu bergen
ohne dabei eine Umweltkatastrophe
auszulösen war eine zusätzliche
Herausforderung
[Musik]
8 januar 2012
da standen wir vor diesem gigantischen
Schiff
diese Aufnahmen haben Passagiere von der
Costa Concordia gemacht
riesig wie ein Wolkenkratzer wenn man
davor steht hat man das Gefühl sie fällt
einem entgegen wir waren absolut
überwältigt meine Frau Laura und ich
waren schon lange nicht mehr im Urlaub
gewesen wir haben uns gefreut wie die
Kinder
[Musik]
das Schiff ist kurz davor mit über 4000
Menschen an Bord abzulegen
das Schiff ist Wohlfühloase und
Freizeitpark in einem
auf 80.000 Quadratmetern können die
Urlauber sich entspannen und Spaß haben
jeder soll seine Zeit an Bord genießen
man ging ins Casino danach ins
Restaurant dann sah man sich eine Show
an machte eine virtuelle Tour ging
tanzen oder hörte Live-Musik es gab
einfach alles
es war wie auf einem anderen Planeten
oder in einem Casino überall funkelten
Lichter alles war vergoldet irgendwie
kitschig aber genau das wollte ich eine
Woche irgendwo verbringen wo ich an
nichts denken musste eine Kreuzfahrt ist
eine riesige Party wir wollten alles
hinter uns lassen und einfach nur Spaß
haben
die Costa Concordia ist das
Aushängeschild der Costa Flotte
damals ist sie das größte jemals in
Italien gebaute Kreuzfahrtschiff
entsprechend teuer war sie auch
450 Millionen Euro
die Investition soll sich noch
Vorstellung der Reederei schnell bezahlt
machen die Kreuzfahrtindustrie ist seit
den 1970ern auf Erfolgskurs der Wunsch
der Urlauber reisen Ausflüge und
Entspannung zu verbinden führte zum Bau
immer gigantischerer schwimmender Städte
Kreuzfahrten gehören mittlerweile zum
Massentourismus
[Musik]
allein auf dem Mittelmeer verbringen 6
Millionen Menschen jährlich so ihre
Ferien
jeden Tag strömen die 3000 Passagiere
der Costa Concordia in die Städte auf
der Route Marseille Barcelona Palma de
Mallorca Cagliari Palermo Rom und Savona
die einwüchige Fahrt macht ihren Namen
aller Ehre la dolce vita im Hintergrund
arbeiten über 1.000 Crew Mitglieder
dafür diese Motto gerecht zu werden
alles auf dem Schiff ist überlebensgroß
die Costa Concordia ist 290 Meter lang
35 Meter breit und 78 Meter hoch
der 18 Decks umfassende Koloss wird von
6 Dieselmotoren angetrieben
[Musik]
man kann die Geschwindigkeit schnell
ändern
sie kommt auf bis zu 23 Knoten
der Stunde
sie ist mit ihren sechs Jahren noch
recht jung aber die Costa Concordia hat
schon 200 Kreuzfahrten auf dem
Mittelmeer hinter sich
an Bord waren insgesamt über eine halbe
Million Touristen
[Musik]
das Prinzip ist auf jeder Fahrt dasselbe
das Schiff fährt nachts und liegt jeden
Morgen in einer anderen Stadt an
es ist zur Katastrophe kommt
[Musik]
es ist der 13 januar 2012 gegen 19 Uhr
gibt der Kontrollraum die letzten Daten
an das Hafenamt durch die Costa
Concordia legt den Civitavecchia ab
das sind unsere Daten an Bord sind
3.2008 Passagiere und 1023
Crewmitglieder unser Ziel ist der Hafen
von Savona
voraussichtliche Ankunftszeit 7 Uhr
[Musik]
das Schiff ist auf dem Weg nach
Norditalien eine einfache navigierende
Route
sie führt nach Nordwesten an der Insel
gilio vorbei bis in den Hafen von Savona
[Musik]
der Himmel ist klar wir bisher in jeder
Nacht seit Beginn der Fahrt die
Passagiere freuen sich auf einen
weiteren unterhaltsamen Abend an Bord
für und Winzer und Bronson ist dies ihre
erste Kreuzfahrt sie wollen sie in
vollen Zügen genießen
an diesem Abend waren wir gerade von
einem Ausflug zurückgekehrt also haben
wir geduscht bevor wir vor dem
Abendessen einen Aperitif getrunken
haben es gab jede Menge barsanbau ich
glaube 7
[Musik]
doch der Abend verläuft anders als
gedacht
[Musik]
20 Uhr die meisten Passagiere Essen
gerade in einem der fünf Restaurants zu
Abend
sie glauben das Schiff fährt auf
direktem Weg nach savone was keiner weiß
sie sind von der geplanten Route
abgewichen jemand hat eine Kursänderung
angeordnet der verantwortliche Kapitän
Francesco escettino
zu beginn der Kreuzfahrt war er den
Gästen vorgestellt worden
ihr Kapitän Francesco Schettino und
seine Offiziere
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sketino ist Absolvent des nautischen
Instituts der Handelsmarine Kapitän
diese Route ist es und dutzende Male
gefahren doch heute würde einen kleinen
Schlenker fahren der das Schiff so nah
wie möglich an der Insel jigilio
vorbeiführen soll es ist ein
außerplanmäßiges Manöver aber manche
kapitänefern es gerne
es hat sogar einen Namen der Gruß diese
Bilder zeigen die Costa Concordia vor
der Insel auf einer früheren Kreuzfahrt
man fährt mit dem hell erleuchteten
Schiff ganz nah vorbei
man macht alle Lichter an
und lässt alle schiffshörner die
elektrischen und die pneumatischen
ertönen
bertramerie war schon auf allen sieben
Weltmeeren unterwegs mit 20 Jahren
Erfahrung als kreuzfahrtkapitän kennt er
dieses Manöver gut
für die Leute auf der Insel ist das
etwas Besonderes
riesige Schiff fährt an ihrem kleinen
Hafen vorbei nur wenige hundert Meter
entfernt man kann es fast berühren sehr
beeindruckend
es ist anspruchsvoll aber machbar
das Schiff muss eine 24 Grad Kurve
fahren
[Musik]
auf der Insel wohnen ehemalige Costa
Crewmitglieder er hat es für sie gemacht
nicht für die Passagiere
[Musik]
es geht also darum den 50 Einwohnern des
kleinen Seehafens von Giglio eine kleine
Freude zu machen
der Gruß soll um 21 Uhr 45 über die
Bühne gehen der Kapitän überwacht das
Manöver persönlich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er saß gerade beim Essen als der erste
offizieranrief und dem sagte wir sind
acht Kilometer vor dem Wendepunkt er hat
geantwortet ich komme dann ging er zur
Brücke es ist 21:34 Uhr als sketino das
Kontrollzentrum des Schiffs betritt sie
sind jetzt 5 km vor der Küste
der Kapitän erklärte dass er das Manöver
übernehmen würde das heißt er hat den
Wachhabenden Offizier von der
Verantwortung entbunden hier hatte jetzt
das Kommando das wurde auch im Logbuch
festgehalten
der Autopilot ist ausgeschaltet alle
warten auf sketinos Anweisungen
[Musik]
das Schiff nähert sich Giulio mit 30
Kilometern in der Stunde
[Musik]
die Passagiere genießen derweil alles
was der Ozeanriese zu bieten hat
wir wollten uns eine Show um 21 Uhr
ansehen sie hatte gerade angefangen es
war auf Deck 3 und ich saß mit meinen
Eltern genau in der Mitte
wir waren zusammen mit einem anderen
Paar aus Paris beim Abendessen wir
tauschten uns jeden Abend mit Ihnen über
unsere Erlebnisse aus so war es auch an
diesen wir hatten ein paar Drinks und
fragten was habt ihr in Rom gemacht was
habt ihr euch angesehen alles war sehr
entspannt
[Musik]
Francesco skittino und sein Team
beginnen mit dem Manöver weil es recht
kompliziert ist gibt der Kapitän selbst
die Befehle
wie der stimmrekorde später zeigt gibt
es ein folgenschweres Missverständnis
zwischen ihm und dem Rudergänger der das
Schiff steuert
340 350 okay 340 nein 350 Steuerbord
sonst fahren wir gegen die Felsen doch
der Rudergänger reagiert zu spät
der Fehler und das Missverständnis
kosten sie viel Zeit während das Schiff
immer weiterfährt
kapitänskettino hat mit dem Wenden zu
spät begonnen jetzt muss er eine noch
engere Kurve fahren um wieder auf Kurs
zu kommen er befiehlt dem Rudergänger
sofort zu korrigieren
[Musik]
doch als das Schiff dreht kommt es zu
einem Problem die Schrauben liegen vor
den ruderblättern am Heck des Schiffs
durch die relativ hohe Geschwindigkeit
und die heftige Ruderbewegung bricht das
Heck zur Seite aus
das Schiff dreht sich um einen Punkte
ungefähr auf Höhe der Brücke liegt
[Musik]
es ist als ob man mit einem Auto auf Eis
fährt wenn man zu heftig lenkt bricht
die Hinterachse des Wagens aus die
Vorderachse bleibt stehen bei einem
Schiff ist das genauso
auf der Brücke wird es unruhig der
Kapitän Erkenner kennt dass das Heck des
Schiffs nicht das tut was es soll dann
haben sie gegengesteuert um das
Ausbrechen des Sex zu stoppen
Frances
zu steuern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Rudergänger versteht ihn wieder
falsch statt nach links Park Bord
steuert er nach rechts Steuerbord
ein Missverständnis mit fatalen Folgen
während die Passagiere ihre Kreuzfahrt
genießen fährt die Costa Concordia immer
weiter seitlich auf die Felsen zu
es ist 21:45
ein Felsen unterhalb der Wasserlinie
reißt die linke Seite des Schiffes auf
sofort strömt Wasser ein
das Schiff machte 16 Knoten so dick die
Stahlplatten auch waren der Rum wurde
aufgeschlitzt wie eine Sardinenbüchse
ich hörte dieses Geräusch vom
Schiffsrumpf
es war so als würden wir über den
Meeresboden Schrammen
alles vibrierte und wackelte wir wussten
nicht was passiert war dann traf mich
einer rumfliegendes Glas
unser Bier und alles andere viel runter
alles flog vom Tisch im Restaurant brach
totale Panik aus
niemand weiß was eigentlich los ist
die über 4.000 Menschen an Bord haben
keine Ahnung was gerade passiert ist
Lora und wenn es um poison sind noch im
Restaurant
[Musik]
befreundete paar neben uns sprang auf
und verließ ohne ein Wort den Tisch sie
liefen einfach weg wir standen auch auf
und fragten was ist denn hier los
Menschen schrien und liefen in alle
Richtungen weg
dann ging der Strom aus und wir standen
im Dunkeln
[Applaus]
ich dachte das ist doch nicht normal was
ist denn hier los
von innen ist davon nichts zu sehen aber
der Fels hat einen etwa 70 Meter langen
Schlitz in die Backbordseite des Schiffs
gerissen
die Crew geht zunächst davon aus dass
die Konstruktionsweise des Schiffs die
Costa Concordia vor dem Schlimmsten
bewahren wird
[Musik]
wie die meisten großen Kreuzfahrtschiffe
hat auch sie unterhalb der Wasserlinie 8
wasserdichte Abteilung wenn ein oder
zwei davon geflutet werden sollten würde
das Schiff trotzdem noch schwimmen
die Frage ist jetzt wie viele
Abteilungen sind beschädigt worden eine
Überprüfung zeigt dass es fünf von ihnen
getroffen hat und in großen Mengen
Wassereintritt für die Mannschaft gibt
es nun keinen Zweifel mehr das Schiff
wird sinken
rum unter der Preis auf der Brücke ging
der Alarm los auf den Monitoren war klar
zu sehen was vor sich ging die
Betriebsparameter die
Sicherheitsparameter es muss sofort
angezeigt worden sein dass es einen
enormen Wassereinbruch
gabino wusste eigentlich schon da dass
sein Schiff nicht mehr zu retten war
tausende Liter Wasser laufen in den
Rumpf die wichtigsten Systeme des
Kreuzfahrtschiffs sind oft die
verschiedenen Abteilungen verteilt die
Stromversorgung für die Motoren und die
bilgepunkten die das Wasser abpumpen
sollen ist ausgefallen es bricht Panik
aus
kapitänske Tino ruft den Ingenieur an
der die Maschine im Heck bedient
ich muss etwas wissen was uns bleibt die
Abteilungen 4 5 und 6 richtig nein alles
steht unter Wasser alles
alles ist überflutet das Kontrollpult
ist komplett unter Wasser
bitte Kapitän alles ist ausgefallen
die versuchen die wildepumpen wieder
zum Lachen aber es funktioniert nicht
besser kommen sie nach Hause wir müssen
hier raus
wir müssen hier raus
okay wir kommen
aber beeilen Sie sich machen sie schnell
aber nicht jemand anderes
ist ein pensionierte offizierter Handels
Marine er ist Experte für die Sicherheit
und die Stabilisierung von Schiffen
[Musik]
schon ein paar Minuten nach der
Kollision war das Schiff komplett
manövrierunfähig und nicht mehr zu
kontrollieren
die Notstromversorgung sprang nicht an
deswegen konnte das Wasser nicht
abgepumpt werden aber das hätte sowieso
keinen Unterschied gemacht
sehr Crew blieb nur das Schiff zu
evakuieren und einen Notruf abzusetzen
die Costa Concordia ist nun dem Wind und
der Strömung ausgeliefert die Passagiere
an Bord sind hilflos
im Gegensatz zum Kapitän und der Crew
wissen sie nicht dass sie in der Nähe
einer Insel sind das macht es für sie
noch schlimmer außerdem sind sie
komplett sich selbst überlassen
gehen Sie daraus auf der anderen Seite
bitte
es war stockdunkel es war eine mondlose
Nacht auch das Wasser das ich Sarah
schwarz ich dachte oh Gott wir sind
mitten auf dem Ozean
jetzt wo das Schiff sich nicht mehr
bewegte war alles ganz still
das war schrecklich weil wir immer die
Motoren gehört hatten sogar nachts jetzt
war totenstill
[Musik]
das einzige was man hörte waren rufe
weinen und Schrei und Dinge die herum
fehlen
die Todes es war eine ganz andere Welt
eine unvorstellbare und absolut
verrückte Welt komplett aus den Fugen
den Kapitän muss der Ernst der Lage
bewusst gewesen sein um meine Panik zu
verhindern und die Passagiere zu
beruhigen lässt er eine Durchsage machen
es ist
21:55 Uhr
ich spreche im Namen des Kapitäns die
Lage ist unter Kontrolle wir haben
Probleme mit den Generatoren deswegen
der Stromausfall unsere Techniker
arbeiten daran das Problem zu beheben
bitte leisten Sie den Anweisungen der
Crew Folge danke
doch anstatt die Passagiere zur
beruhigen hat die Durchsage den
gegenteiligen Effekt viele machen sich
Sorgen und telefonieren mit ihren
Angehörigen um zu erzählen was los ist
um 22:10 Uhr 25 Minuten nach der
Kollision meldet sich die Küstenwache
beim Kapitän
guten Abend Costa Concordia haben Sie
ein Problem
ja bestätigt es gab einen Stromausfall
wir machen uns gerade ein Bild der Lage
was genau ist denn das Problem nur die
Generatoren
die zeige meldet
sie hat ein Verwandten angerufen er sagt
die Decke des Restaurants sei
eingestellt nein das stimmt nicht wir
haben nur einen Stromausfall und
überprüfen das gerade
Francesco skittino bleibt weiter untätig
er verschweigte Küstenwache die wahre
Situation und verhindert dass sie die
Passagiere retten kann und das obwohl er
weiß dass die Lage aussichtslos ist
die Costa Concordia ist jetzt 3
Kilometer vor der Insel Giulio die
Steuerung treibt sie weiter aufs offene
Meer sie könnte jederzeit zu sinken
beginnen doch zum Glück kommt in
Passagieren der Zufall zu Hilfe
leicht auf die rechte Seite gekippt
dadurch hat es nun sozusagen eine
Segelfläche
eine riesige Fläche auf die der Wind
trifft und es so dreht
es nimmt nicht an Fahrt auf aber es
bewegt sich genug um sich in den Wind zu
drehen
das Kreuzfahrtschiff kommt zum
Stillstand der Bug steht im Wind die
Ruder sind rechts verklemmt das Schiff
dreht sich wieder der Wind treibt es
erneut auf die Küste zu doch hier wartet
eine neue Gefahr auf die Passagiere
da waren Felsen denen wir immer näher
kamen ich sah einen Kormoran der dort
nistete
kann man Größen und Entfernungen nur
schwer einschätzen ich dachte wenn der
Kormoran so groß ist dann sind wir ganz
nah dran wir krachen da rein
sagten wir runter runter ganz schnell
wir bekamen Angst wir waren immerhin auf
einem Schiff das ziemlich schlagsalter
hatte wir versuchten ruhig zu bleiben
keine Punkte an denen wir uns
orientieren konnten wir sahen uns von
Deck aus Omaha konnten absolut nicht
sehen nichts
[Musik]
der Wind traf auf die Backbordseite und
schob das Schiff seitlich auf die Felsen
zu am Ende lief es mit der
Steuerbordseite aufgrund auf der
Backbordseite war ein gewaltiger Riss zu
sehen
[Musik]
20 Minuten lang gibt es keinerlei
Anweisungen von der Crew die Passagiere
wissen nicht wie sie sich verhalten
sollen
in ein paar Stunden wird das Schiff
komplett zur Seite kippen denn in jeder
Minute die verstreicht laufen tausend
Liter Wasser in den Rumpf und bringen es
immer weiter aus der Balance der
Schwerpunkt des Schiffs verschiebt sich
jetzt zählt jede Minute um 22 Uhr kommt
endlich eine Durchsage mit der
Aufforderung die Costa Concordia zu
verlassen über eine Stunde nach der
Kollision
bitte verlassen sie das Schiff verlassen
sie das finden Sie
nicht rückblickend
wir bekamen die Anweisung das Schiff zu
verlassen
da hat man die ganze Anspannung erst
richtig gespürt die Angst von 4000
Menschen die plötzlich erkennen dass es
ernst ist jetzt ist es offiziell Text
doch richtig Angst
das aufgrund gelaufene Schiff ist nicht
das einzige Problem jetzt drängen 4000
Menschen zu den rettungsboden
lassen Sie ihn vorbei es herrscht Chaos
nein alles voll
in manche konnte man noch rein aber es
war
im Irrenhaus
[Musik]
und die Passagiere wissen immer noch
nicht wie Nazi der Insel sind
[Musik]
Giorgio van Julie lebt oft Giulio er
schlendert am Hafen entlang als er
plötzlich die Costa Concordia sieht
als wir sie sahen wunderten wir uns dass
sie überhaupt noch oben schwammen
aber nicht unter das war wirklich
seltsam ein Wunder eigentlich
50 Meter weiter draußen wäre sie
gesunken und es hätte keine Rettung
gegeben
sie wären wahrscheinlich alle gestorben
vor gilju fällt der Meeresboden steil ab
die Costa Concordia ist auf einen der
wenigen felssporne der Insel aufgelaufen
als sie gekippt ist wurde sie von zwei
Schafen Felsen aufgespießt die sie nun
an Ort und Stelle halten
[Musik]
das Schiff hat so stark Schlagseite dass
das Hauptdeck bereits komplett unter
Wasser liegt nur noch ein Rettungsboot
ist übrig es fasst 250 Menschen doch
jeder will die Costa Concordia Lebens
verlassen
ich ging nicht zu dem Rettungsboot ich
wurde geschoben meine Füße berührten den
Boden gar nicht aber ich habe es ins
Boot geschafft so als hätte man mich
hochgehoben und reingesetzt ich war
total eingequetscht mein Brustkorb wurde
zwischen meinem Mann und der Person auf
der anderen Seite zusammengedrückt ich
sagte zu meinem Mann so geht das nicht
ich werde erdrückt ich setze mich vor
dich auf den Boden er antwortete bist du
verrückt sie werden eine Plan über uns
werfen und dann erstickst du
[Musik]
250 Leute da drin dann schien es als
hätten sie die Seile durchgeschnitten
ich muss man konnte nicht sehen
erst der Rumpf auf dem Wasser aufkam
dachte ich oh je jetzt sind wir richtige
Robinson crusos wir müssen bis zur Küste
Rudern
würde weil ich keine Ahnung hatte wo wir
waren
sie sind nur ein paar hundert Meter von
der Küste entfernt
die ersten 1000 Passagiere kommen im
Hafen an
wegen francescos Lügen kommt der erste
Rettungshubschrauber er ist sehr spät
beim Schiff an mit den Infrarotkameras
machen sich die Piloten ein Bild vom
Ausmaß des Desasters sie sind schockiert
sie sind wirklich
näher anfliegen
sehen wir uns das genauer an
hast du immer noch viele Menschen an
Bord
haben unglaublich so viele Menschen auf
einem sinkenden Schiff
die Piloten der italienischen
Küstenwache sind fassungslos sie hat mit
einem Stromausfall gerechnet tatsächlich
ist die Costa Concordia gecantert vor
ihren Augen spielen sich chaotische
Szenen Passagiere hier in Weiß haben
sich auf die Seite des Schiffs gerettet
manche versuchen auf den Rumpf zu
klettern und bringen sich so in noch
größere Gefahr das Wasser ist 60 Meter
unter ihnen sie können nicht einfach
springen dann versuchen Sie über eine
Strickleiter nach unten zu klettern
Leute vom Schiff zur Küste
ich kann es nicht genau sehen ich glaube
es ist einer
[Musik]
das ist ein Mensch großer Gott
es ist eine Leiche
Lora hat Glück nach nur 15 Minuten im
Rettungsboot hat sie festen Boden unter
den Füßen
und ich sah eine Menschenmenge dutzende
Leute hauptsächlich Männer streckten uns
ihre Hände entgegen um uns rauszuhelfen
ich griff nach einer ich kann mich noch
genau daran erinnern wie mein Fuß den
Boden berührte ich dachte wow ich bin
wieder an Land
[Applaus]
mehrere hundert Menschen sitzen immer
noch auf der Costa Concordia fest dort
koordiniert niemand die Evakuierung der
Grund so unglaubliches scheint Kapitäns
getino hat das Schiff in einem
Rettungsboot verlassen ein Mitarbeiter
der Küstenwache von Livorno ruft ihn auf
seinem Handy an
[Musik]
nehmen Sie
mir bitte sie müssen auf das Schiff
zurückkehren mir wurde gesagt
Rettungsboot
[Musik]
das machen sie gerade
was koordinieren sie denn da gehen sie
zurück aufs Schiff koordinieren sie von
dort weigern sie sich nein das tue ich
nicht sie haben dazu aufgefordert das
Schiff zu verlassen jetzt habe ich das
sagen
gehen sie weinen gehört sie sollten wir
das eigentlich sagen können
aber es ist dunkel und wir können nicht
sehen na und wollen sie nach Hause gehen
Tino weil es dunkel ist okay Kommandant
doch Francesco skittino geht nicht
zurück aufs Schiff er fährt zum Hafen
und nimmt sich ein Zimmer in dem
einzigen Hotel der Insel bis zum
nächsten Tag wird er nicht mehr gesehen
die Einheimischen kümmern sich während
der Nacht um die geretteten ich erinnere
mich wie wir uns irgendwann ansahen und
sagten wir sind nur 50 aber es werden
4.000 kommen
[Musik]
zum Beispiel suchten wir nach welchen
die zu erfrieren drohten brachten sie
zusammen und versuchten sie so schnell
wie möglich aufzuwärmen
alle mit Kindern sammelten wir in der
Dorfschule
Mario Pellegrini ist der
stellvertretende Bürgermeister der Insel
er steigt in ein Rettungsboot und fährt
zur Costa Concordia sein Ziel so viele
Passagiere retten wie möglich
als ich zum Schiff kam hing da eine
Strickleiter herab das war ein ganz
schöner Kraftakt
eine Strickleiter nach oben zu klettern
die hin und her schwingt ist gar nicht
so leicht
suchte ich nach einem Verantwortlichen
aber ich konnte keinen finden
Pellegrini hilft dutzenden Menschen auf
den Rumpf zu klettern und rettet neun
Passagiere in einem abgelegenen Teil des
Schiffs vor dem sicheren Tod
[Musik]
sie waren in einem Flur eingeschlossen
ich schaute nach einem Seil aber aber
nur ein dünnes Kabel gefunden das mir in
die Hände geschnitten hat
damit habe ich neun oder zehn Menschen
aus dem Flur gezogen
stand das Wasser bis zur Hüfte im
letzten Mann bis zum Hals
am Ende
ich sah das Wasser rein strömen da habe
ich wirklich Angst gekriegt
war komplett auf die Seite gekippt das
Wasser lief rein und raus ich kann mich
noch genau an das Geräusch erinnern es
klang wie ein Wasserfall
der letzte Mensch den ich rauszog sagte
etwas dass mich noch tagelang verfolgt
hat
ich habe die Leiche eines Vaters und
seines Kindes durch das Fenster eines
der Restaurants gesehen
um 4 Uhr morgens ist das Schiff
vollständig evakuiert bis dahin gibt es
sechs bestätigte Todesopfer dutzende
Menschen werden noch vermisst
ein paar Stunden später nimmt die
Polizei den Kapitän wegen fahrlässiger
Tötung fest
[Musik]
nach und nach rückt eine andere Frage in
den Mittelpunkt wie soll der havarierte
Ozeanriese gebaut werden
[Musik]
mittlerweile hat eine Fähre alle
Überlebenden zurück aufs Festland
gebracht im Laufe der Zeit kehrt für die
Bewohner der Insel gilgio der Alltag
wieder ein doch das gigantische
Schiffswrack im Hafeneingang erinnert
sie jeden Tag an die furchtbaren
Ereignisse dieser einen Nacht
niemand hatte mit der Bergung eines
solch riesigen wrackserfahrung
jeder fragt sich wie geht es jetzt
weiter wird die Costa Concordia
auseinanderbrechen aber vor allem wie
können wir diese ständige Erinnerungen
das Unglück loswerden
ran ist Sonos
auf der Insel wollte dass das Schiff
dort bleibt wir wollten dass es
verschwindet auf der einen Seite weil
wir Sorgen um die Umwelt hatten aber
auch weil es uns ständig an diese
Tragödie erinnerte
wir sind hier zwar keine tourismusinsel
aber wenn unser mehr verträgt ist trifft
uns das trotzdem schwer
ausgewählt im Volksvertreter galt
deswegen meine erste Sorge dem Schutz
unserer sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
Lebensgrundlage
[Musik]
schnell erkennen die italienischen
Behörden was für eine Herausforderung
die Bergung tatsächlich darstellt die
besser Concordia ist das größte
Passagierschiff das je auf grundgelaufen
ist niemand hat ein havariertes Schiff
dieser Größe je wieder zum Schwimmen
gebracht die meisten Experten wollen es
nicht einmal probieren sie halten die
Bergung für unmöglich und glauben dass
sie bei einem Versuch sinken würde
allein ihr enormes Gewicht ist ein
Problem mit über 100.000 Tonnen wiegt
die Costa Concordia ungefähr so viel wie
12 Eiffeltürme ohne das ganze Wasser in
ihrem Rumpf endlich findet sich ein Mann
der sich der Herausforderung stellen
will Nick Sloan ist einer der wenigen
Experten weltweit die sich auf die
Bergung von Schiffen spezialisiert haben
der schiffbauingenieur und Erfinder hat
über 30 Jahre Erfahrung auf diesem
Gebiet im März 2013 über ein Jahr nach
dem Unglück kommt er von Südafrika nach
gilio trotz seiner Erfahrung ist der
schockiert von dem Anblick der sich im
bietet
in Video
ich fuhr mit der Fähre nach jillio und
sah sofort dieses riesige Schiff auf der
Seite liegen
so groß wie drei Fußballfelder
dann sind wir ganz nah dran
vorbeigefahren 20 30 Meter am Bug vorbei
ich dachte meine Güte wie konnte das
passieren es ist eine Tragödie wirklich
unfassbar als wir dann an Bord waren und
ganz nach oben kletterten konnte ich
nicht mal das Ende des Schiffes sehen es
schien immer weiterzugehen
[Musik]
Schiffe dieser Größe können
normalerweise nicht im ganzen geborgen
werden man zerlegt sie an Ort und Stelle
doch dieses Mal muss nichts lohn sich
etwas anderes einfallen lassen
zum Schutz der Umwelt mussten wir das
Schiff in einem Stück da wegkriegen mit
allem was an Schadstoffen in ihm drin
war
außerdem war es wie ein riesiges Hotel
mit tausenden Zimmern
Vorhänge Teppiche Lebensmittel aus den
Restaurants das musste alles drin
bleiben
[Musik]
slone weiß dass diese einzigartige
Bergungsaktion Jahre dauern wird die
geschätzten Kosten sind entsprechend
hoch 500 Millionen Euro das ist mehr als
die Costa Concordia selbst gekostet hat
und es gibt keine Garantie dass es
klappt
viele meinten das ist unmöglich die kann
doch nicht im ganzen bergen sie wird
auseinanderbrechen
[Musik]
500 Techniker Ingenieure und Taucher
werden an dem Projekt mitarbeiten
[Musik]
an die David
130 Taucher 45 Ingenieure es mussten
über 22.000 Tauchgänge gemacht werden
es war die größte tauchoperation der
Geschichte und ein logistischer Albtraum
ein zusätzliches Problem die Costa
Concordia liegt so ungünstig dass sie
jeden Moment siegten könnte schon ein
kleinerer Sturm könnte zu einer großen
Katastrophe führen sie müssen sich
beeilen
zuerst stabilisiert nix lones Team das
Schiff um Unfälle bei der Bergung zu
verhindern
das Schiff durfte sich nicht mehr
bewegen damit es für die Taucher nicht
zu gefährlich wurde
unten war nur ein Meter Spielraum
zwischen Schiff und Felsen
wenn es sich bewegt hätte hätte ein
Taucher schnell eingequetscht werden
können also haben wir 18 Löcher ins
Gestein gebohrt und von dort Kabel unter
dem Schiff verlegt die wir mit einem
hydraulischen Hubsystem gespannt haben
[Musik]
allein das dauert sechs Monate
dieser Zeit erlebt die Insel ein ganz
neues Phänomen
[Musik]
und bin zwar
wir hätten nie daran gedacht dass wir
von Katastrophen Tourismus betroffen
sein würden
viele Besucher kamen nur für einen Tag
das einzige was sie wollten war ein
Blick auf das Schiff zu werfen
von den Stammgästen kamen dagegen immer
weniger
sie störte das Wrack verständlicherweise
um das frag abtransportieren zu können
muss es zuerst einmal aufgerichtet und
dann schwimmfähig gemacht werden damit
es beim Aufrichten nicht auseinander
bricht muss es auf festem Untergrund
liegen
[Musik]
wir brauchten etwas das die Unebenheiten
ausglich und den steil abfallenden
Meeresboden
riesige aufblasbare Säcke kommen auf den
Meeresboden eine mühsame Prozedur do you
Lover
am Anfang sind sie leer damit man sie
besser verlegen kann
dann befüllt man sie mit Beton und sie
werden Stau zusammen bilden sie eine
waagerechte Ebene das war eine wichtige
Voraussetzung für die weitere Bergung
insgesamt werden 18.000 Tonnen Beton in
die Säcke gepumpt die schließlich einen
25 Meter hohen festen Untergrund bilden
dann bauen die Ingenieure eine riesige
unterwasserplattform auf der die Costa
Concordia liegen soll sobald sie
aufgerichtet ist die ganze Konstruktion
ist so gigantisch selbst
von unserer Archiv die Plattform war
riesig es waren drei Teile die zusammen
so groß waren wie ein Fußballfeld 25
Meter hoch und 45 Meter breit als wir
das Schiff aufrichteten lag es komplett
raus
es ist ein Verrückter Plan erst werden
auf der oben liegenden Seite riesige
Tanks angebracht dann wird das Schiff
aufgerichtet
anschließend werden auch auf der anderen
Seite Schwimmkörper montiert die werden
dann voll Luft gepumpt und die Costa
Concordia schwimmt wieder
als erstes muss das Team die
gigantischen Schwimmkörper auf der
Backbordseite anbringen
[Musik]
wir mussten dem Schiff zwei seiner
grundlegenden Fähigkeiten wiedergeben
Auftrieb und Stabilität
wir haben außen Schwimmkörper angebracht
wie bei einem Baby im Pool das
Schwimmflügel trägt damit es nicht
untergeht
[Musik]
sie sind so groß dass sie in einer Werft
hergestellt werden
ironischerweise ist es dieselbe die auch
die Costa Concordia gebaut hat
sie hatten die Ausmaße eines Gebäudes
mit einer Wohnfläche von 110
Quadratmetern und 7 bis 10 Stockwerken
ein kleines Hochhaus
davon brauchten wir 30 Stück um den
Frank Auftrieb zu geben musste alles
unglaublich groß sein also haben wir
quasi um die Costa Concordia eine zweite
Costa Concordia gebaut
[Musik]
die Schwimmkörper werden an die Seiten
des Schiffs geschweißt und dann mit
gewaltigen Kabeln mit der Plattform
verbunden
[Musik]
wenn die Kabel dann eingezogen werden
soll sich der Koloss aufrichten aber
eine Bergung in dieser Größenordnung
wurde noch nie zuvor versucht es gibt
also keine Erfahrungswerte darüber wie
sich das Kreuzfahrtschiff Verhalten wird
[Musik]
nach eineinhalb Jahren Arbeit ist der
große Tag endlich gekommen die ganze
Welt schaut auf jillio
wir wussten nicht wie lange es dauern
würde weil nicht klar war wie schwer das
Schiffe
beim Aufrichten wirken enorme Kräfte
dadurch besteht die Gefahr dass das
Schiff auseinanderbricht die Anspannung
im Kontrollraum scheint mit Enden
greifbar wofür wir fing mit 2000 Tonnen
Zugkraft an dann warteten wir 15 Minuten
danach erhöhten wir jedes Mal um 500
Tonnen und warteten wieder damit sich
die Belastung auf die Struktur des
Wracks verteilen konnte und nicht an
einem Punkt zu stark wurde wir erhöhten
weiter aber nichts passierte
[Musik]
ziemlich nervös weil wir mehr Kraft
aufwendeten als wir gedacht hatten wir
hätten das Schiff zerstören können jede
Minute rechneten wir damit dass etwas
kaputt ging vielleicht würde sich das
Schiff drehen oder vorne plötzlich
absacken
endlich bewegt sich die größte Concordia
6000 Tonnen Zugkraft auf dem Kabeln
führen zum Erfolg langsam hebt sich die
Steuerbordseite aus dem Wasser es war
als würden wir die dunkle Seite des
Mondes sehen da wurde uns das ganze
Ausmaß des Schadens bewusst
arbeiteten wir nicht mehr mit den Kabeln
denn die Schwimmkörper hielten sie
aufrecht wir haben noch ihre genaue
Position korrigiert und sie dann langsam
auf die Plattform gesenkt
um 3 Uhr morgens setzte sie dann genau
in der Mitte auf
[Musik]
dann haben wir alles abgeschaltet und
uns ein Bier aufgemacht
[Musik]
das Kreuzfahrtschiff liegt wieder
aufrecht im Wasser aber es kann nicht
bewegt werden
40.000 Tonnen Wasser in seinem Inneren
drücken die Costa Concordia auf die
Plattform
[Musik]
viele Leute waren überrascht dass sie
nachdem wir sie aufgerichtet hatten
immer noch 10 Stockwerke oder 32 Meter
tief im Wasser lag
das sind 70% des Schiffs um es
schwimmfähig zu machen werden an seinen
Seiten weitere Schwimmkörper angebracht
[Musik]
das Schiff hatte noch nicht so viel
Auftrieb dass es nur noch 18 oder 20
Meter tief im Wasser lag
das entspricht 66.000 Kubikmeter und
botzahlen wir hatten nicht genug
Spielraum auf der Backbordseite
dort mussten wir genauso viele
Schwimmkörper anbringen wie auf der
Steuerbordseite
denn wenn beim Anheben des Schiffs
irgendetwas nicht richtig ausbalanciert
gewesen wäre hätte es auseinanderbrechen
können
die Kräfte die auf das Schiff einwirken
müssen gleichmäßig verteilt werden wenn
das Team nicht mit äußerster Vorsicht
vorgeht könnt ihr die Costa Concordia
verbiegen oder die ganze Konstruktion
kollabieren die Ingenieure hoffen dass
die zweieinhalb Jahre Arbeit von 500
Menschen sich nun auszahlt und sie den
Koloss wieder zum Schwimmen bringen
können
am 14 Juli 2014 ist es endlich soweit
die Bewohner von Giulio erwarten mit
Spannung die Auferstehung des
Ozeanriesen auch einige Überlebende des
Unglücks sind gekommen noch ist in den
Tanks Wasser doch sie sollen nach und
nach mit luftfolgepumpt werden so dass
sie das Schiff anheben und über Wasser
halten
hier und da ein wenig Luft rein und
gucken was passiert ob sie leichter wird
der Stahlgigant erhebt sich langsam aus
dem Wasser sind die Meter für Zentimeter
jedes Mal wenn ein Deck aus dem Wasser
auftauchte warteten wir
damit das Wasser aus dem Wrack abfließen
konnte
es dauert eine Woche das Schiff 17 Meter
aus dem Wasser zu heben dann geschieht
endlich das was sich die Bewohner von
Giulio so lange gewünscht haben
[Musik]
die Costa Concordia wird nach Genua
geschleppt wo sie abgewagt werden soll
ihre Bergung hat die Reederei Costa
cordiere rund 1,5 Milliarden Euro
gekostet es ist dreimal so viel wie der
Bau des Schiffs Nick Sloane ist
erleichtert als er es wegfahren sieht
damit ist seine Arbeit beendet und er
hat allen gezeigt dass es möglich war
du lebst 24 Stunden täglich nur dafür
du hörst es du fühlst es wenn du es zu
Ende gebracht hast ist das ein
fantastischer Moment
doch dieses Hochgefühl wird dadurch
überschattet dass es immer noch Familien
gibt die nicht mal die Leichen ihrer
Angehörigen gefunden haben
wir leben hat sich für immer verändert
viele der Überlebenden sind
traumatisiert die Havarie der Concordia
war eine große Tragödie
im Moment
in diesem Moment dachten wir das könnte
ein freudiger feierlicher Anlass sein
wenn wir alle hätten retten können aber
das konnten wir nicht
ich frage mich immer wieder was ich noch
hätte tun können
viele Menschen sehen in diesem Schiff
einen schwimmenden Sarg das Relikt einer
furchtbaren Nacht während der
Bergungsarbeiten wurden zwei weitere
Leichen entdeckt insgesamt kamen bei dem
Unglück 32 Menschen ums Leben der eigene
der Costa Concordia hat den Opfern
Entschädigungen gezahlt und leistete
2013 nach einem Vergleich außerdem eine
Strafzahlung von 1,3 Millionen Dollar
2016 wurden zwei Offiziere und der
Rudergänger des Schiffs zu mehreren
Monaten Haft verurteilt Kapitän
francescos getino wurde zu 16 Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt am 12 Mai 2017
wurde seine Berufung abgelehnt und das
Strafmaß bestätigt der letzte Akt der
Tragödie
[Musik]